people showing up in Mass the public
demonstrations is a very scary fact
people showing up at people's homes
invading people's private spaces for
political reasons that's a very alarming
fact these are signs that liberal
democracy is becoming extinct Andrew you
still sound optimistic about this
country what what and there's people who
are not why are you optimistic I'm not
optimistic I have hope you have there is
a distinction between those two
the First Amendment means that at some
point unlike you guys we will always
have the right to air criticism of
whatever is happening which to my mind
is the only real guarantee of preventing
disaster
for the last however many elections I
look at the candidates which have been
presented to us by both left and right
and go is this really the best America
has to offer you're on the right you're
going to vote for a left Winger over
Trump yes and you're gonna so that's the
option
foreign
welcome to trigonometry welcome back
thank you welcome to Washington DC thank
you uh we're all in a very good mood we
are it's beautiful out there I mean it's
a lot of pollen yeah it's a sort of
arboreal bukaki out there today it
certainly is in a good mood so having a
clean my eyes I'm very happy to be here
it's great to have you on man uh listen
one of the things we wanted to talk to
you about is uh we've been here for this
is probably it's our second trip we've
been here for about a week and it's
always interesting coming because you
see the media coverage and then you see
reality and they don't always
necessarily match up and you are still
British uh we've been told you still eat
the crappy British food even while
you're here I prefer it you prefer it
right so you're true you're True To Your
Roots uh what do you see what's going on
in America tell us educate us educate
our audience
I think we're in a cute case of
acute cultural and political
tribalization and polarization and this
is a banal
fact and it's something everyone says
but then when you see the society
attempt to actually resolve any issues
you find it in complete crisis
and
the democracy and the institutions that
we set up
seem to be struggling to achieve any
kind of compromise on things that could
actually work so we're even I think
going to face the possibility of you
know a debt default because not because
it's anybody thinks it's a good idea but
because we simply can't compromise and
that worries me worries me for many
different reasons and it's accompanied
by a shift in the public discourse and
in the culture in which the very
epistemology in many ways of liberal
democracy have disappeared
the epistemology of being just an
individual person having a view on the
world regardless of your position in the
culture the notion that there is
something other than power there are
things like truth and Justice alongside
power
um and I think the notion that a little
bit better
if it violates some of your core tribal
instincts is no longer deemed possible
and so you'd rather things got worse
than actually in any way compromise
those two things together
are are dangerous to Liberal democracy
and I and and I think
the failure in many ways uh to resolve
that under the Biden Administration we
had a a chance in some ways maybe is not
working uh
currently and you know things change a
lot
I think the likelihood of trump becoming
president again is not insignificant
and especially since both the uh the
mainstream media and the Trump media
hate any alternative to Trump
because Trump is fantastic news for the
left and uh and you mean because they
get to make money they get to make a
huge amount of money but they also get
to use him to legitimize and validate
their extreme views of America in other
words this is horrible ratchet in which
when someone like me comes along and
says look yes we know
and you'd be immoral and stupid to deny
that the legacy of slavery and racism
segregation and so on is not a huge
thing but there were many other things
in America alongside that including the
long struggle of Americans to overcome
that that help Define who we are as a
society that becomes very hard in this
context very very hard
simile it's very hard to say something
like which is what I've been trying to
say which is
uh
we fully accept trans people as fully
realize citizens in our society and in
fact the Bostock Supreme Court decision
only a few years ago granted them full
civil rights under the 1964 Civil Rights
Act the gold standard for civil rights
protection but we should be able to have
pragmatic conversations about Minor
parts of it in other words uh and I I'm
echoing actually I think like King
William William Hague my old friend
William Hague when when I don't have a
problem at all with treating
transcendental women as translated women
in the law in the culture in person
in almost every single respect if
they've done the right thing and are
formally recognized as transgender and
we can talk about but the the tiny
marginal issues involved here they're
very marginal in which it actually does
matter biologically which aren't that
many it's it's kind of a a handful
Sports obviously
and it's crazy we even have to debate it
there's a legitimate debate about
prisons and shelters
I think
um and there is a very important
question about
how you deal with children with gender
dysphoria including the majority of them
who are gay
and what's the right way to help them
grapple with that dysphoria those are
not questions the civil rights as such
they're questions of medicine their
question of prudence of judgment
they should be able to be resolved we
should be able to compromise them but we
can't because they're not questions of
anything like that anymore they're
question of politics they're a question
of tribal loyalty more than anything
else so you know so one side is now
coming to the point where all
transgender people are are have to be
denied this is the Matt Walsh Michael
Knowles position which I think is
ridiculous and stupid and yes to some
extent
ambiguity to the strong word but it's
denying the Dignity of people to
describe their own experiences and lives
as they really are and telling them they
don't know who they are and that's a
just a not good way to do it
um
uh why not all you have at the left
which is like any conceivable
restriction on this is genocide
yeah genocide and you hate us
and and what I'm trying to say is that
voice in the middle that says yes but
this is the yes but position which I
think is the only same position for most
people have on any topic I agree I agree
with you but I would like to ask you to
articulate because you we've had our
issues with Matt Wallace and backs and
forth and whatever but the reason I I
wanted to ask you about that is you
mentioned truth earlier right and Matt
Walsh would say not uh unreasonably in
some senses the truth is you cannot
change your sex right so why are we
pretending and you say people have a
right to to find their own experience
but no only I mean again this is this is
It's problematic because we don't have
sort of some objective measurement in
which we could say this person trans
this person isn't right the science
isn't there we just don't know
but I will tell you this
uh that the trans people I know and have
gotten to know over in my lifetime and
whom I've interacted with I really do
not believe are lying about who they are
and and the precise disjunction they
feel between their core psychological
identity and their body now quite what
that is is it is it and and and I and I
would say that because as someone who
had to explain to people I am genuinely
not attracted to women I'm only
attracted to men I don't know why you
can't point to some scientific then it
will prove it or otherwise but I know it
and I'm not lying to you
I extend the same respect to them that
they would respect that they would
extend to me in that respect and and
obviously if people are mocking this
abusing it
making a making an absolute mockery of
it
then we should have some means to say no
um and there should be a process by
which someone has to kind of prove that
this is happening isn't just a sort of I
feel like it today
um without making it overly ownership
and these are compromised things
I think we want to live in a society in
which everyone
possible has human dignity and is
accorded it publicly
and I don't think they're lying I do
think they're a transgender people in a
way that I think Matt washed does not
and I I've just because I've seen it
with my own eyes and I don't think
they're lying to me and I think if we
can accommodate them in some way
great fantastic why why would we not
that's why I mean actually with the
women's Institute question
for example I'm sort of with William I
was like you know well you figure it out
first of all we shouldn't ban them all
but it you know if this appropriate
habit you know I think you should also
Biden has actually done something quite
interesting recently he put out a new
Title IX policy about this in sports
and for the first time Biden broke with
the [__] he's [__] left
this was also going so smoothly that you
were coming across seriously in a good
way I've always thought that's the word
I mean it's the thing like Dan Savage
going into a trouble about this is
because he said this too like several
years ago he was completely been symptom
of perfection in the gay World okay I'm
gonna claim my lgbtqia 2x we're gonna
get a rainbow flag out for you yes but
not with the uh the the the the invasion
arrow in it like
the the LGBT ptqi plus swastika as I
call it but yeah it's horrible it's not
about gay people anyway uh where am I
going where was what was I saying uh so
why not like I have but again you were
talking about you said no blanket ban
we're not going to allow all transgender
we're talking about only about
transgender male athletes also so for
example no transgender
men should be discriminated against in
sports they they don't have an advantage
at all
um they're discriminated against by
reality what no no the actual the ftms
who are running in men's sports are
actually somewhat likely to be injured
or hurt they're the ones that's what I'm
saying right right okay uh
as for the ftms
um TFS
female tomato yeah mtfs MTS mcf's I'm
sorry it does get a little you can get
your head can get little do you know
what's amazing before we get into this
right I haven't asked you about trans
and yet every conversation eventually
boils down to trans and this is why this
is I'm sorry it's my mind
it's not your fault because we end up
talking about a lot and my point is this
is why it's an issue because it is the
Eternal conflict between truth and self
the desire to self-identify to describe
yourself the way you want and I think it
is different from being gay Andrew not
that I know anything about being gay
although I may find out
being gay does not require other people
to pretend things are true that are not
right that's the difference here if I
demanded that you recognize that I could
have
a baby by [__] my husband yeah then I
would think you were nuts
obviously we can't uh but babies don't
live as someone would say
you're getting the lesson in anatomy
right here right now
I'm just talking to you as I might talk
to a friend of mine I'm not
uh what was the question my point is the
reason this issue comes up organically
is it's a fundamental is the demand that
other people lie that's why people don't
like it yes if I am told I mean but but
in most of the cases you're not it's
kind of a white lie in most cases it
seems to me I'll give you an example of
George W bush who at the White House had
a Yale reunion
and one of his classmates showed up who
had transitioned from male to female and
he and and as he was in as she
introduced herself to
to W
um so well you may not
remember me quite as like this and he
said well I'm glad you've Come Just As
You Are
that's a classy statement of decency and
civility
and insofar as we can do that and affirm
the Dignity of of the set of the gender
that people represent we should it's a
good thing it's horrible to mock people
horrible to marginalized people like
this and what it does to the the psyche
which is already struggling
with this horrible difficult conflict
between who you feel you are and who you
appear to be uh it can be a compounding
horrible thing and I don't see why we
shouldn't be treating those people with
dignity and respect and you can in
almost every circumstance that's my
point practically speaking
a trans person comes into your presence
why would you bring it up we employ two
people with gender dysphoria you don't
have to explain
we're good people but then if you ask me
as a human being sorry that this person
who's been female since birth and this
person whose transitioned to be female
if there is no difference between them
at all
I can't because there is
that that's that's the key so don't make
me have to say that because I don't
because it's not true because you're
forcing me to position which we don't
have to get to by and large
it seems to me the far right and the
farthest want us to get to this
impossible point
because they both want us to resolve
this in this essentially illiberal way
one way or the other and our task is to
create the space in the middle whereby
we can say yes let's treat all
transgender people as the gender they
say they are as long as it is in good
faith and done correctly
um but but that's where sorry I I want
Francis to jump in but just to finish
this comment but this is where the
problem comes because we see in Scotland
a two-time rapist you know we jokingly
call a prison onset gender dysphoria
right turns up in the courtroom suddenly
transgender so when we talk about good
faith the problem is that it's the at
the extremes as it always is that these
issues have to be decided hard you're
either male or you're female and if you
are capable of inserting your penis into
a woman who doesn't want that that's a
problem and that's where there's some
circumstances and that's where I know
and I'm with you on that and I and I'm
frustrated
uh people demanding acceptance of
unreality as a condition for there being
part of the even political discourse
it's crazy uh and it's contrary I think
to creating an atmosphere of acceptance
for transgender people I think they've I
think the Transcendent people have gone
backwards I think I think gay people
because we've been completely now mashed
up with every transgender manifestation
some of which is deranged and unhinged
along with every single variety of drag
queen which is also uh has a huge
Spectrum uh and some of them are bathing
inappropriately but most are not
um and most are completely harmful
harmless uh so yeah this is the problem
liberalism depends on our ability to
have some some some
moderation and some flexibility in the
middle allows us to say again yes but
our left and right are profusing
refusing to let us do that isn't the
problem Andrew that left the hard left
hard right uh ideologues they conform to
an ideology and the problem is with an
ideology is it creates a rigidity of
thought so you can't say yes but because
the moment you do that then you are
question in your ideology which means
you're going to be expelled from the
tribe because you're and the reason you
shouldn't do that is because you are
former for first and foremost a member
of the society not a member of your
tribe and you have an obligation as a
democratic citizen
to compromise and our entire system of
government is set up designed for
compromise especially in America where
the power is dispersed massively now
some of that you can see it work now you
can see federalism happening you can see
some states blue States in which kids
are going to be told you know it's going
to be handed dildos at the age of two or
something I mean
in which
sure here's my main issue with the
education of children and then you're
going to have states where
poor trans kids have no capacity to find
anyone who can help them and that that
worries me a great deal too uh and and
I'm also not I'll be honest with you I
don't want to ban all of it because I
think in some cases there are some
outline cases in which if if conducted
within a clinical trial these
experimental treatments in hormones and
impurity blocks can be legitimately
defended in a few cases so again I don't
want to make that an absolute thing too
so Biden's thing of no blanket ban but
you figure it out in the localities in a
pragmatic way should work in a liberal
democracy
whether it can or not will reveal the
extent to which we have the semblance of
that left
um I mean I find myself in a weird
position because obviously I have
sympathies in both camps I'm I'm very
strongly conflicted about this on many
issues like on the issues of religious
freedom
as both I believe in Catholic and a gay
person
uh I have to weigh those things up
um but I as a citizen
who is neither the Catholic nor gay but
as an American citizen I favor a
compromise
um I favor like not forcing someone
against their conscience to do something
they don't want to do and in favor of
encouraging gay people to find someone
else to bake a cake or or or or run a
wedding because
if you can't find a gay florist you you
yeah I don't know where you are
I don't have to go to another state it's
it's every small town has one anyway no
I was gonna say there is a philosophical
argument to be made that all florists
are gay but
I think that's an outrageous assumption
yes but yeah yeah
but I I listen to what you're saying
Andrew and I agree with it and I think
partly is is because you're right and I
think but there's there's a there's a
there's a more crucial part which is we
grew up when there was no social media
when we weren't incentivized to be in
these tribes when we weren't
incentivized to all think the same isn't
that what's really going on here is that
social media is driving us all insane
it's definitely making things a lot
worse
I don't think it's a sufficient
explanation
um but I do think it's absolutely
necessary part of the explanation I do I
mean I do think in America you also have
this very straight and in most of the
West you have this very interesting
educational divide that's going on which
is related to the economy and the
culture to some extent
um but and you also have this
ideological shift in which in which
wokeness is capturing the left and a
kind of of a white identity politics
has is in danger of capturing the right
um and in which the left is regarding
anything that they don't believe in as
somehow illegitimate and the right does
too increasingly um you also have in
America this strange geographical thing
in which the Democrats are so
concentrated into big urban areas and
the Republicans are so evenly spread out
that there is a a really uncanny balance
between these two which you first saw in
2000 when the Country Split right down
the middle the first election in which
we said red and blue actually those are
the first time when we switched the
colors around just to confuse you guys
um and and I think that was 50 50 and
it's kind of remarkable how 50 50 it is
um and that's just the demographic
accident but yeah I think social media
by incentivizing
conflict
and also the other troubling thing
anonymity
uh I I I've never both the anonymity
online but then you also very
frighteningly see it on the streets
people wearing masks
this is a this is this isn't this is one
of these signs you should be on the red
red button list of things that are going
wrong people showing up in maths the
public demonstrations is a very scary
fact people showing up at people's homes
invading people's private spaces for
political reasons that's a very alarming
fact these are these are signs that
liberal democracy is becoming extinct
um and the alternative liberal democracy
is the permanent political war a sort of
permanent called Civil War and we have
been doing that on and off now for quite
a while in a country and it's not like
this divide is not manifested itself
throughout American history it has
um but it's a very tough time in which
we don't seem to have many people
capable of
negotiating a sane Center
and why is that because I completely
agree with you and for the last however
many elections I look at the candidates
which have been presented to us by both
left and right and go is this really the
best America has to offer 300 and what
20 million people and we get Biden or
Trump next time as well that's the
amazing thing next time as well I mean
there's going to be Weekender Bernie's
up up again up against you know this
crazy
malevolent mobster person and both in
their 80s but definitely what bothers me
about it it's like Joe Biden who's
present right now he he whatever you
think about Trump is a bit different
because he's still with it right but
Biden isn't even in his own Prime you
you couldn't even get a guy who is at
his own best to run the country No in
fact someone who really should be
retired I mean but don't think Trump is
I mean Trump gives you a you should look
at a tape of trump from 20 years ago and
look at it now he's but he and he's also
clinically unwell
um quite clearly a delusional Maniac
um I mean the sheer vehements with which
he consistently even now
asserts that the 2020 election was a
landslide victory for him
this is someone who was saying something
equivalent in our private life we would
we would
get that person into a mental hospital
that's how crazy this man is that's
delusional and he believes it
because his psyche won't allow him to
believe anything else he's still saying
this Constantine
at what point do you say this person and
he could uh you're not a fan
I think it's a dangerous evil Maniac yes
and I I my task number one
uh is preventing him returning if that
makes me have to vote for a left-wing
Democrat I will you're on the right
you're going to vote for a left wing out
over Trump yes and you're gonna so
that's the option look I supported him
look I'm open to him I'm open to your
argument you can't have a lunatic
running the Western world but he did get
elected and I understand that he's very
provocative and he says things that
aren't true and that annoys me what has
he done that makes you makes you think
he is an evil lunatic I think those are
the words you used I think attempting to
prevent
the actual I mean this is something we
some of us said
before he got elected in the first place
that he will never concede to defeat
uh and therefore we'll we'll create a
constitutional crisis because his psyche
does not allow him to lose whatever the
reality says the fact that he refused
that he is currently engaged in an
assault on American democracy currently
engaged in
still spreading the LIE
still mandating others spread the LIE uh
and was clearly complicit in an attempt
to prevent the peaceful that person
should be in jail
can I do you mind if I yeah or Exiles
but the but the other amazing thing is
that 45 of the cup well 30 of the
country would follow him to the gates of
hell and 45 percent would put him back
in the White House
this episode
brought to you
better help
help Constantine what's the best thing
about having this episode sponsored by
betterhelp in my country mental health
is something that you have before you
start drinking thankfully we'll start
drinking at breakfast so we have no
problem really yes our slogan is drink
breakfast vodka and become real men okay
but if you do want to feel better inside
and out then maybe you should try better
help I have been doing therapy for over
a year and it has really helped me
understand myself better and become far
more effective in both my work and my
personal life I always knew you were not
real men pass me the Vodka therapy has
helped me transform myself so that I
take responsibility for my behavior and
my attitude you can't achieve your
dreams if you don't think you deserve to
every shot you drink make you feel
stronger what is problem and the great
thing about better help is that it's all
online and they can connect you with a
licensed therapist who can work with you
so that you can achieve your goal it
takes a few minutes to set up and it can
fit around your schedule I will never
forget my first love Olga orgasmachenko
and the Beautiful relationship that
could have been any if it's not working
for you with a particular therapist then
you can always switch at no extra charge
I am doomed to become Russian poet
discover your potential with better help
visit
betterhelp.com
trigger today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trigger
I have run out of breakfast Vodka it's
time for lunchtime Brandy
I was very troubled by what happened on
January 6th and I said so at the time uh
even though I what happened wasn't an
Insurrection in my opinion but but I was
troubled by what happened and the way
that it happened what I'm curious about
though is I think it's fair to say look
I I always try to put myself in the
shoes of the people I'm talking about
and Donald Trump was called every name
under the sun and I remember
um this was a complete shock to me are
you honestly saying we should worry that
Trump's been called names no no I'm
gonna get to no that's not what I'm
saying at all just give me a second to
lay the argument up
in 2018 my wife and I watched uh one of
the Die Hard movies
and this is at the peak of you know
Trump as evil fascist nazi whatever
and
there's a scene in that movie I think I
may have talked about on the show before
where
because of something that happens they
have to run the switchboard for the
entire city through one woman
in an office somewhere
and her supervisor comes in he's a white
guy she's a black woman this is a black
woman
and he says to her you're going to have
to run the switchboard for the entire
city and she says if you think I'm gonna
do that you think I'm going to marry
Donald Trump
prior to him running for president this
guy was an aspirational figure in this
country is that fair to say am I being
unreasonable for some deluded people yes
there were a lot of men who wanted to be
him and a lot of women who wanted to
marry him or sleep with him or whatever
it would have been right he comes he
runs for president he's treated as a
joke
he gets elected he gets called a Nazi
now I'm from a Jewish background Donald
Trump is not a Nazi his daughter married
the Jewish guy who he gave a a big role
in government and converted to Chris to
Judaism
he gets whatever you may like him
dislike him whatever but he has been
misrepresented from day one now I agree
with you he's a complete narcissist and
and a malignant one in terms of the way
that he behaves but I'm thinking about
me I get [__] on on the me in the media
social media every day now every
interview we do
if I was being misrepresented at that
level
how would that affect how I behaved well
if you also said you wanted to shoot
protesters dead that you believed in
that sounds like something I would say
uh when you have when you have the
authority of the presidency United
States of course when you violate when
you delegitimize the entire system of
what you were elected and vowed that it
won't that such a thing will be when you
actually attempt to seize voting
machines to rig them when you ask a
governor to just invent votes to get you
into office
uh when you support war crimes openly
when you say you want to bomb other
countries like Mexico without the
declaration of war when you say you want
to steal oil from and it can go on and
on and on this this man's public
positions
are so extreme that they're duterte
level he wants to execute drug dealers
without trials
you could you could you he's right out
there right now saying these things you
can read what he puts up on his
true social and it is not
distinguishable from someone in a mental
hospital
and he is also belligerent malevolent
and capable of doing things to other
people that are fundamentally cruel and
enjoy it
such a person has no place
in a Democratic Society and he was
always this way by the way and you say
he's misrepresented if you so much as
misplace a comma he will be offended he
is the most it is the most incredibly
thin-skinned person imagination we can
agree on that but what's happened and I
get what you're feeling because people
feel this way as well is that the way he
was completely dismissed Milan and not
only that but his voters more
importantly the voters who supported him
were treated this way they feel like you
or like I do I'm called a Nazi all the
time I'm white supremacist I'm
homophobic get up every morning thinking
of what harm I can do to some poor trans
child that's that's what that's that's
how I'm now it's very easy emotionally
to then Retreat into your tribe to say
well whatever you're saying about that
I get it emotionally and I think people
in the country feel that emotionally and
if they're pushed to make some emotional
Choice are you with them or with us they
will say with us again but at the same
time I don't think most of them have
given an opportunity to vote for someone
who was sane who represented some of
Trump's positions I think many of them
would be quite happy to do so they just
don't want to put on the spot and they
don't want to be harangued by the left
media and they are right when they're
told they're being propagandized in many
ways and condescended to in many ways so
all that I understand I do because I
feel it myself and I've been vilified
and
lies just complete lies about you
uh in order purely to diminish your
credibility your legitimacy because as I
said they only believe in power they
don't believe in truth they don't
believe in rebutting you
because that's not what they believe and
they believe in destroying you
uh and the Zeal with which the far left
actually Joy's taking on individual
human beings you know a succession of
Emmanuel goldstein's to vilify and hate
is really chilling really and this is
why I bring up this point because my
worry is that in that sort of media
environment where look the moment you
you've got the Arty next to your name
you become a Nazi if you're running for
president that is what they do
some people would argue I'm not saying I
agree with them necessarily but some
people would argue the reason Donald
Trump was successful is he he doubled
down instead of cowing and cowering he
wasn't successful though Constantine he
did get elected he got elected with a uh
I mean by with a minority of of the
popular vote he just squeaked he
squeaked in uh I mean he was
legitimately elected
uh lost every single election ever since
his own party consistently losing the
people he nominated on and championed
last time around losing this is not
actually uh we could have a third
uh loss
um coming up in 2024. now
if if however social media the culture
the Democrats whoever want to turn this
into uh whose side are you on
then it could get quite close and it's
perfectly possible he could be
re-elected my nightmare scenario is
Biden keeps Camilla
which is what he's one of his biggest
mistakes uh and sort of there's a moment
in like the four campaign where Biden
completely loses strain of thought in
public uh or has a heart attack or
something because you know this happens
it's not completely unknown and it
becomes Trump come alone we have a trump
Lance on it
and then where were we
and then once the cities go up I mean we
are on the edge of islands here if we're
not careful this is a question actually
that I wanted to ask you because there's
a lot of people who talk about the
potential for Civil War in this country
and there's a lot of people online and
we know those type of people who make a
lot of money out of it and they
sensationalize it and they always talk
about it and it's scratching that very
unpleasant itch how close do you think
we are to things going really awry in
this country I don't you're not going to
have
the
Confederacy and the Union forces are
Marching together and finding a a
battlefield in the in in the middle of
Virginia to fight it out that's not
gonna happen
the truth is also this idea that
that there is a very clear divide
between red and blue States is is most
red states have some very blue cities in
them it's it's a it's it's going to be
more I think
political paralysis the dysfunction of
the states as the counties and and an
attempt by the Republicans also to kind
of rig the system even more to their
favor in some of these big uh Central
States so that uh they can get
legislative majorities that are out of
proportion to their actual I mean
gerrymandering I mean um but that means
that you can't have a whole bunch of
States against a whole bunch of other
states it's too muddled up we're there
are lots of red State as in [__] more
than you would think you're sitting in
the one place where that's not true
which is DC
um but almost any big state will have a
variety just go to Virginia go down a
few lines you'll see Trump sizes on and
so forth so I know that can happen but
what you can have is political paralysis
and then incipient terrorist uh outrages
mass shootings designed to ferment
even further uh hatred of the other
um you see you know I I like in a
transition you could have some incident
I mean we kind of almost did with the uh
the shooting the school shooting we
don't know quite what that person's
motivations were and they've kept the
manifesto out uh but when you're
creating these levels of of divine
divide and hatred Mutual hatred uh this
country has a lot of guns there's a lot
of Mayhem that can happen it would be
more like that
you have to remember also in the first
remembering the 70s there were there
were there were bombs going off you know
every other day in this country there
were riots everywhere it's not like this
is completely unprecedented
um the 60s and 70s late 60s early 70s
were unprecedented in terms of political
violence
um it happens in America it's a violent
place
and there's there seems to be a lot of
anger here as well like I see the
disproportionate anger now look take for
instance Dylan Mulvaney advertising Bud
Light the reaction that both sides have
had it's insane you go this is a person
who identifies as a woman whatever you
think of them advertising a beer is it
really the big issue of the day have we
not got more important things to talk
about yet it's become this flash point
for both left and right yeah I know I'm
I'm I'm riveted by doing Mulvaney for a
frontal reasons and I was actually
riveted by him
uh many many months ago because
it's an interesting case I I I I this is
not a trans woman
this is a gay man I mean it's a very
recognizable gay man making fun of women
becoming a parody of women it's a form
of drag
a a kind of musical theater kind of drag
taken to the ultimate because he he
figured if he couldn't become famous in
the Book of Mormon or or in other and
like he really went on The Price is
Right I think at some point to do the
same you can see the same act that he's
doing as a man that he's doing as a
woman there's no difference between him
before and after transitional except for
the dress
and the marketing
and his use of social media namely Tick
Tock he's not even becoming a woman he's
becoming a girl
now
this strikes me what amazes me is why
the trans movement isn't saying hold on
a minute this person is the idea this
person represents your average trans M
to F is it is absurd
in fact it's a sort of parody of what it
might be not just to be a woman but to
be some sort of absurd girly girl who
can't do math and can't walk can't run
and can't throw and he does this he does
this whole gay boy Act
day six and six being a girl and today
I'm in nature
love ya
oh did you see that I gotta get out of
here so I just I I just look at it and
I'm just this is kind of Staggering and
then of course
it takes off and he gets all this and
then all these dumbass
uh Lefty liberal PR appetizing people
just so then he's the Superstar I wait
that's my weight is he really committed
to living his life as a woman or
committed to living his life as a girl
performing for money in front of
audiences I think the right word for him
is Minstrel
uh that it's he's performing as a
Minstrel
he's he's telling especially straight
women nothing to be afraid of here
and I can represent all the cool things
you like about gay men pretend to be a
woman and Vibe with you and be your best
gay friend basically that's who he's
being a best he's being the classic best
gay friend to a straight woman that's
the line that's why he's selling all
these Goods because straight women love
him
do they I mean I know a lot of straight
women that absolutely despise him that's
probably true but a lot don't a lot
think this is super funny and cool and
it's sweet and lovely and he's all about
love and is against hate and uh look
there is I mean I'm just I'm just maybe
I'm wrong in identifying that but they
wouldn't be doing this for no reason and
he is popular I think he's just a really
weird
and a very idiosyncratic eccentric event
I don't think it symbolizes anything
except maybe the crisis that we're in
that such a person can become so
prominent and be taken
seriously in a way in which I really I
really think there are plenty of people
who have transitioned from male to
female who would find his parody of
their experience kind of disgusting have
we not just here on the very core of
this difficulty though because we talked
earlier about accepting people the way
that they want to be and yet here you
are you have unilaterally made the
decision I haven't I'm just giving you
my impressions as a gay man if what I
see in that picture now now you
understand I'm playing Devils absolutely
I do but if you were to go along and
then if she he would go along and
actually do the actual transition and
but most trans people don't have the
transition no but if they if he were to
uh
changes passport or change his ID from
male to female I think that would be a I
don't think he's done that to be honest
with you I don't know all the details of
that but I think that's TBD
um I've just seen things like I watched
Milo for example he was a another kind
of minstrel appealing to another kind of
audience
um and
you know it didn't end particularly well
no it it didn't it and I think this is
the very core of it it's just you look
at all of these things and you go
it is weird I'm sorry it is strange and
those of us who spent like 30 years in
the gay rights movement as it were
our core objective was to remind people
a few things and this is this is what we
kind of we did in the in the 80s and 90s
really we said we just want to be like
you
we don't want to change your life in any
way maybe you'll be a little
uncomfortable because we're around but
you know can't help that
um we're not going to make you change
your pronouns we're not going to make
you do anything different at your
marriages we're going to not gonna if we
join the military we're gonna you know
we're just gonna be treated the same as
everyone else and all of this will be
fine and everyone was sort of cool after
a while you know there was some initial
hostility and panic and fear and then it
slowly and now we have 70 support for
those things
what we did was
emphasize what we have in common with
everyone else
not what sets us apart in other words
what we were doing was a Universalist
human experiment what they're doing is a
very particularist identity based
uh defense of it which appeals to no one
because it it's not even asking anybody
to agree or disagree it's demanding it's
demanding obedience because again this
comes down to philosophically
if you believe in power if you believe
in truth they don't believe in truth
they don't believe there's any stable
truth let alone about biology or
anything else
um
so the only way they can do this is by
the exercise of raw power which is
either just enforcing things and
demanding it like the American Medical
Association is now doing
um or demanding that you use certain
pronouns or not or smearing and
targeting and demonizing anybody who
speaks up against not saying their
arguments are wrong because this isn't
this but spanning God knows how much
time and energy saying that someone like
JK Rowling is somehow an evil human
being when it's quite obvious to any
sane person that she is not but that's
what they do because they don't have
the muscles for argument they do not
actually want to stress what they have
in common with everyone else it is a
kind of adolescent temper tantrum that
has always been there within gay
politics within the queer movement and
which many of us in the 80s and 90s were
like if we carry on like this we're not
going to get even basic protections or
even basic respect to many of us who
were not identifying that way who was
the last thing on earth I would call
myself is queer uh uh it felt as if the
movement didn't really exist and we came
in and the movement actually did shift
and it did succeed
but then we succeeded and we left
because I'll go I thought well I'm
concerned once he got a basic rights our
job now is to get on with our [__]
lives and actually do something with
them and so that this stuff is not
obsessing it's about going forward it's
not about obsessing about who you are
um and uh
so we quit and then they got to Define
it all
and the trans people come in and the
queer Theory people come in who are
always there but were kept somewhat at
Bay
and they just took over and they've
gotten rid of the entire older
establishment of the gay rights
organizations they are the most militant
they are the least Democratic they are
the most authoritarian
and they borderline violence and
offensive
their discourse if you compare our
arguments to marriage equality with
their vicious insults just the way they
just say things like [__] you into
people's faces in a demo there are other
ways of demonstrating you know than
saying [__] off or I want you to suck my
[__] dick
we didn't we didn't say that when we
were asking the right to me
it's also defeating and it's it's it's
done a lot to put back
along with this [__] words that we
have to use like lgbtqia plot and and
gender affirming care all this [__]
and I think there are a lot of people
who who just feel like they've been this
has been imposed on them and [__] you
and it's the word Queer as well and I'm
glad you brought it up because so a lot
of my family from Venezuela and I have
there's a saying in my my family are
called LA palisas and there's a saying
you know police says that you're either
ugly or you're gay right those are the
two choices so I grew up with a lot of
gay men who were closeted in Latin
America and seen what they had to go
through and now this I actually find it
it actually pisses me off when people go
I'm queer and they just it's just an
identity it's just something to play
with and I'm like it's identity slumming
that's what I call it it's it's like Sue
I'm so cool I'm queer now it's like I
was some some dude on Twitter a couple
of years back I think which is like this
nice middle-aged guy with a nice wife
and two kids and a little picture of him
on Twitter and he's like some academic
and he just said this I just decided a
day that I needed on Twitter to come out
as queer
I'm queer now and I and I just tweeted
back no you're not
if but if you are if that is that's the
point the point of the left is to take
career and expand it Beyond homosexual
well first of all to co-opt every
homosexual into it with how [__] dare
they
suddenly decide that because they they
they're the lobby group that controls
the New York Times The Washington Post
and sends them guides to the words they
use
if it's suddenly we have the word queer
used in the New York Times ubiquitously
as simply a neutral descriptor of gay
people
again in position power not persuasion
anyway and then they'd lie that this has
happened spontaneously and organically
no it hasn't I mean there's a bunch of
Ivy League gays have suddenly decided to
call themselves that uh
uh so
I don't think it's going to succeed I
think it's gonna
hurt actually and I think I think uh and
I think that's gonna be even a lot of
trans kids in red States and gay kids in
blue states are going to suffer from the
fact we either have All or Nothing in
terms of treatment of of children with
gender dysphoria for me
the one point I want to make is this on
that question is that if you tell a
three or four-year-old boy
who might be feeling maybe I'm not like
the other boys I like this I like
playing Barbie I like reading I like I
don't like playing rugby or whatever if
you tell them you can be a boy or a girl
or both or neither
or something else entirely
uh and they're told this is a choice for
them
it is quite possible
that a young gay boy will internalize
that is the idea that I really should be
a girl
and that breaks my heart it breaks my
heart
because everything we try to do which
was to tell gay boys you do not have to
deny your maleness to be gay you don't
have to renounce your sex to be gay
uh is being undone
and the stereotypical
models and behaviors that are being fed
into the minds of these children but
what we fought against
uh and the impact on gay kids
people don't talk about they always talk
about trans but many of them are not
trans many of them are gay and Confused
um and most the vast majority of kids
with gender dysphoria we all know
resolve it in puberty and go on to be
gay the question for gay people is how
many of us are being
uh siphoned off that path by well meant
but overly invasive engineering of these
kids before they're really capable of
making these proper decisions for
themselves this is about gay kids
that's why they insist on lgbtqa that's
where they take all these very different
experiences and and and and and
identities and mash them all into this
queer thing so they can prevent these
tensions from being aired
well they will be aired
um but what's happened is that because
of tribalism
the vast majority of gay men are going
to shut up
they can't support the scientists they
can't support these right Wingers they
can't support the Republicans they can't
support the world just right therefore
they're fine
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands thousands in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra of three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
Andrew we had a whistleblower on the
show from a UK from a US Jamie Jamie
absolutely Clinic who yeah I thought it
was last week right yeah it was last
week and for people who haven't seen it
she is a gay woman who is married to a
trans man and she made the point that
this movement is homophobic
we'll tell you to that
I would say that there are elements of
homophobia in it that are undeniable
um the move in which you say that
gender Trump sex means that means that
same-sex attraction becomes problematic
because you should be same gender
attraction that's position of Stonewall
in the UK but gender that would mean
that the gay man should be attracted to
someone who has a vagina who is
biologically still female
um and as I I've said to people the last
person who told me
to get over the fact that I needed to
that I didn't want to have sex with a
vagina was a priest
and now it's a trans activist
and the the Deep the D hostility to
homosexuality comes from our proud
ownership of our own sex
that we are men loving men
we're not some other and in fact
traditional societies and regressive
societies really have a problem with
that I mean we all know that the the
world center for transitioning children
is Iran
uh because they cure homosexuality
by transitioning children
uh
the fact that those those areas I
brought these I'm one of the few people
to bring this question up because it's
so toxic and it really is taboo on the
left to say that there might be some
conflict between gay and trans
identities uh even though because again
again it comes back to philosophy
as far as they're concerned the only
thing that matters about gay and trans
people is they're the victims of
Oppression they're not interested in
actual
who they are as individuals what might
have affected them how they interact
with Society they're not seeing you
they're not seeing us at all they're
seeing oppressive forces controlling I
mean it's a it's a mindset that once you
slip into is really hard to get out of
them to see the individual person and
human again I I was going to lie in the
mood and move on to something but I
actually you sparked a thought on me
which is
uh if people talk about Marxism all the
time and it's misapplied massively in a
lot of cases but the one thing the
Marxism introduces fundamentally into
the way we view the world is the idea of
zero sum for me to win you have to lose
are you either oppressed or you're the
oppressor right and the entirety of our
social existence is explained by that
and this is so antithetical to anything
that makes Society good if you think
about the relationship between men and
women being positioned as a zeros what
men and women two groups of people who
for the entirety of human existence have
had to work together to survive now
these people are being positioned as
enemies and it seems to be happening
everywhere and the right will take it on
when it suits the right and the left is
obviously just gone crazy here's the
difference the difference is the Marx
who is a historical materialist
um unlike these unlike Foucault or
unlike Schmidt or some other people have
influenced the the the the new left for
him the class forces that were zero sung
were in these constant Warfare but
eventually it had a dialectic that at
some point would lead to communist
Nirvana Utopia would suddenly end the
history it had a it had an eschatology
within it in which it would Suddenly at
some point break out into sunlight
this stuff has no moment like that it is
marked without the happy ending
it is an eternal grind of power against
Power there is never space for Freedom
you will always be defeated you'll read
Tallahassee coaches between the world
and me what he's telling his black son
is that there is never a place for you
here America was built to destroy you it
will always destroy you it is designed
to destroy you
uh and we just have to
suck that up and accept it and and
develop a kind of uh some kind of
offensiveness to it and critique it and
try to overthrow it maybe one day
but the idea that it could be overcome
not there it's deeply pessimistic that's
why it's very alien to America actually
and this is what I was going to say
because uh changing this this will feel
like a gear change of gigantic
proportions you like it here don't you
you love being in it you love America I
do we love America every time we come
here you know last time we came here
we did the whole trip and you know Rogan
was like you guys should move here and
did you know everyone was you guys
should you guys should and Francis and I
were like yeah we should move here then
we got back and you know we I we him and
I argue about this but I feel like we
have a mission in the UK we are you know
some one of the few people doing what we
do in the UK and trying to bring sanity
to these conversations and I feel like
we have a purpose and a mission there
it's not to say we'll never move but for
the moment
this time we've been here a week we came
back day one end of the day we're just
sitting there going we need to move to
America right and we won't do it right
now but I I think it's hard to resist to
be honest
with all I've been given what I've just
described about the cultural crisis and
the political the problem is and you may
not know this anymore Andrew or maybe
maybe you do but whatever you guys flush
down the toilet here we get served for
breakfast the next day in the UK that's
the way it works plus on top of that we
have and I don't know I don't know if
this was the case when you left or no
but we sort of feel like
it's very difficult to to work to build
to create when the entire society around
you is sort of designed to pull people
down if they tried to do that so what do
you like about this country what is it
what is it that makes it great well
we'll say one thing the banter here is
[__] the banter is terrible that's not
good I know uh I mean there are elements
of British culture you all forever miss
and the banter though that you miss
the sardonic constantly sarcastic
skeptical of everything
unfortunately that's part of the package
you know that that that that that also
I'm I'm disheartened because exactly
what you said
is how I first encountered America with
the first I mean I'm a natural
Enthusiast Builder I do things I'm I was
like I was named pushy fresh Paradox and
I was like the most sort of like I just
want to I want to do plays and I want to
give speech I want to do this I want to
do that and everyone was like who do you
think you are like where did you come
from what school did you go to they in
in Ireland they call this they say he's
got the Notions yes the Notions yes the
idea that you should aspire to something
and be something is is considered you
know offensive or vulgar vulgar
and you know I've I apprec there are
elements in which that matters
so it means that England will never
really have a bout of enthusiasm in like
some crazy person like Trump I don't
think because he would be taken no one
would take it no one could get he Trump
is proof that there is a great deal of
uh sanity in the English position I I
take it and the same with you know
Orwell's famous notion that the English
would be fascist because if they people
will like Goose step down the the the
straight people would just would just uh
uh sneaker they would just laugh at it
it was just silly uh so I get it and
I've come to appreciate that but I also
totally agree with you that when I came
here and I said I want to do this good
for you
uh uh why not oh yeah
go for it [__] yeah
he's America has a word sure
no equivalent in English we've got fine
you've got fine the Europeans see see
see is it is a is a positive optimistic
emphatic Yes No Such Thing exists in the
English language
um how you doing great man not too bad
uh how you doing [__] yeah you know it's
like Muslim Grumble
um
I immediately loved it I felt this was a
place where I I honestly wrote my
parents in letter after about six seven
weeks saying I know this sounds crazy to
you but I feel like I've come home there
was something about the
the individualism here the ability the
lack of of risk of of apparent ceilings
even though uh as a gay person you could
see I mean as a gay person Coming to
America I had to on the first time sign
that declared I was not a homosexual
just to get into the country that
existed until the 90s wow but I also saw
like you saw
that if I were to shift the debate here
on something like gay marriage
that mattered in a way that it wouldn't
if I'd done it in Britain and I could
have spent a lifetime in the Tory party
trying to persuade David Cameron to to
do equal marriage or whatever which they
did which I'm very proud of that they
did but if I could turn American opinion
first and help shift that debate it
would have that consequence that
America's America is still where the
future is invented that's why the stakes
of this debate in America are so
fascinating and great because it really
is about the West
and the values that we're going to
uh believe in and Americans like the
future West in as much as it is much
more multiracial Multicultural than the
past
so if we can get this right here
it's really good news if we get it wrong
it's really bad news for you guys
so my instinct as an ambitious person
was to get near where the real power was
and to see what I could do to affect
things in that way
um and
I you know I have
I have some feelings that if I'd stayed
in England you know I was president of
the Union I was going to do the natural
I was following you know I was gonna I
would have been among that almost
certainly if I'd gone a bit among that
generation of Boris and he was a year
below me and Cameron maybe all those
people and would have known them uh
pretty well
um but didn't
um uh and then I think of
you know this about me my high school
friend Kiera
um who I spent five years debating with
Roger grammar and now he's the leader of
the opposition probably going to be the
next prime minister uh and part of you
thinks wouldn't it be great if I was
battling here like we used to do on the
424 bus in the morning
uh at the dispatch box of the House of
Commons it's not something out of
it's not it's not a crazy idea that
might possibly have happened in some way
or other and I'm not I'm here
um but you know life's weird you you you
take you take a decision at one point at
least to a million others elsewhere
um
the men here are also immensely hotter
than in the United Kingdom certainly in
the United Kingdom of the 1980s and 90s
it's a little bit more it's a little bit
fresher now in London and London has now
become this like crazy sex pit really uh
uh but um
so no I love this place this white broke
my heart to see someone like Trump win
the presidency and
uh and it's been really good to me
I can't imagine for example a 25 year
old American being named editor of The
Spectator but that was the equivalent of
what happened to me when I was in my 20s
in this country in the new Republic
that's an amazingly open Society
Almost Never
what right do you think you have to come
here and mouth off for you I'm born here
the most you get is liberals telling me
they told me about Obama you don't
understand you don't grow up in this
country they'll never elect a black
president they're never
you don't get it
I'm like
Maybe not maybe the Immigrant is
actually the person with the best
understanding of America because it's
the best Spirit of America but again
we've also seen then that Spirit of
immigration be threatened in many ways
again because it wasn't
it wasn't pursued properly in the past
or in the present or now of course we
just can't [__] solve it because we
can't agree uh tomorrow we could build a
million dollar War I mean there's
nothing stopping the Congress or
president from doing the things that
would stop illegal immigration
uh I mean technically speaking but the
politics and the culture of it prevents
it from occurring Andrew you still sound
optimistic about this country what and
there's people who are not why are you
optimistic I'm not optimistic I have
hope you have there is a distinction
between those two
uh of course I have hope you look at the
history of this country it's an
incredibly boisterous unpredictable
young Dynamic Place 320 30 million
people across a continent is a country
which has Miami and Seattle it has
Alabama and Minnesota it's just simply
possible to Discount this place
and its constitutional system is not
finished I mean we you know at some
point we'll look back and see this
period of populist turbulence and see
how well the institutions did
um
I don't think they completely failed I
mean they've been pushed and pushed and
pushed if Trump wins again there's going
to be a trust a stress test of immense
proportions
uh
but
power is still pretty much dispersed
there is a variety of different policy
options we can judge them
the First Amendment means that at some
point unlike you guys
we will always have the right to air
criticism of whatever is happening which
to my mind is the only real guarantee of
preventing disaster
um and we're a lucky country for [__]
sake it's vast huge amounts of Natural
Resources huge numbers of people
happily less overly regulated in tax
country which means that we consistently
produce more growth more Innovation
we're leading the major industries of
the world
um
it's a it's a crazy ass wonderful
nightmare of a place
and I think that makes it very different
than most other countries and you either
are appalled and call home and
or you you you embrace the uh
you embrace it it's the energy here yeah
of course it is the energy it's it's the
sure energy yeah yeah it's it's
addictive here because like you said
it's the opportunity it's that
everybody's here to make it everybody
wants to make it there's not the sense
of being dragged down like you get in
the UK while you're doing that it's less
where are you from then where are you
going where are you going and that's
what I love here it is it also means
you're going to get a bunch of [__]
crazy people in this country you're
going to get extremes of right and left
that are going to be even more wacky
than elsewhere I mean just this we're in
the anniversary of the Waco
situation
how could you imagine that happening in
any other country on earth a religious
sect hold up up against an absolutely
idiotic bullheaded ATF tanks
immolation of 90 people I mean the whole
thing is out of out of Waco
um and the one really weird thing about
America though I'll tell you this uh
it's a vast and exciting and it's
incredibly paranoid
Americans have this deep strain of
paranoia and you think of I can imagine
someone born in alzace Lorraine being
paranoid about who's going to come next
the Germans or the French I don't really
see whose turn is it now we're in the
middle of [__] desert in the middle
of America you're worried about two vast
oceans and they're coming to get you
well no one's coming to get you guys
except yourselves
um but uh that's a little part of it too
unfortunately I think some of the and
again it's sometimes the old system did
really to keep part of America out the
one thing I think you should say about
Donald Trump is that he does represent
something real in America absolutely
cheesy awful
self-aggrandizing money grubbing vulgar
capitalist uh crony capitalist it's
worse
they deserve to be represented in the
white house as well to some extent he
represented part of America that we're
kind of ashamed of but that is real I
think he also represented I know it
seems like I'm a massive Trump fan I'm
not but uh just to play to complete the
picture perhaps
um yeah it's got little magger symbols
in his shirt
he sewed them in he also look this is
the disease of the West
is that I am very concerned about which
is there are far too many people and I
talk about in in my book about this in
the west who have accepted this idea
that Steve Bannon when he talks about
how he got Trump elected
cause manage decline there are far too
many people and in Britain this is even
worse than it is in this country far too
many people who feel like we've had our
turn and now it's time to roll over and
die
and people in this country thank God
don't want to hear that and so the the
Macabre expression of that that is
Donald Trump
is
your concerns about it many of them in
my opinion are completely legitimate
but
someone has to say we're not We're Not
Gonna We're Not Gonna Roll Over and die
we are the most powerful civilization in
the history of the world and we'd quite
like to stay that way please thank you
very much right someone has to say that
someone has to say that and if if no one
is willing to stand up for that Andrew
people like you and people like me are
not going to be very comfortable in the
foreseeable future so I understand all
of that but
you know the West is only great as long
as it's willing to be great yeah the
question is whether the championing of
the West As Trump understood is really a
championing of the West as Reagan
understood it for example probably not
very very different
um and and I and I do think in fact that
what's happened is that we're sort of
becoming more of a late 19th century
model in America where the natural
position uh certainly in terms of
foreign policy or is stay out to someone
extent we like our place here it's it's
it's it's we escaped all that [__] we
don't want to go back into it the
natural but that was the Republican
party is the natural party of
isolationism if you want to use a
pejorative term but you might call it
just americanism but we escaped history
we don't want to have to reenact it we
certainly don't see the point from the
middle of Colorado of why we have to
expend possibly risk the survival of the
earth over the Integrity of the island
of Taiwan God knows how far away which
was always part of China anyway that's
going to be a breaking point so but but
but that's quite because once the Cold
War was done once the great ideological
enemies of Nazism communism were
defeated the more natural
interests of a great Continental power
over here will assert itself so in some
ways I think
that element the neoconservative Remake
the world for democracy stuff the
wilsonian stuff that's in retreat but I
don't that's just one kind of
americanism this is another completely a
more a more rational concern americanism
I think uh
uh it just if you just look at the
geography and if you look at the
economics you look at all the it's
natural for America to be a a distant
power that kind of balances other powers
rather than running the whole [__]
place
and I think that will assert itself
um
but I also don't I mean is it true
really about Britain everyone's given up
I mean there is a sense in which Britain
will never could never be what it was I
mean that there's a point I mean
Churchill kind of [__] with us with
the greatest speech ever uh if the
British Empire lost a thousand years
this will be this was their finest hour
I grew up being told that the finest
Hour of my country was already passed
and I should be proud of that
and there was a sense in the second
world war that that we kind of
sacrificed ourselves for the greater
good as it were
um of the world and of democratic values
and of resistance to totalitarianism
we're not entirely untrue to some extent
uh but there's no way Britain can be the
country it was in the 19th century
there's no way even conceive of being
such a thing of course but I was going
to say Andrew but Hang On You Came of
age in the 80s in the in the early 90s
you're a child of Thatcher Britain was
booming the city loads of money we were
successful we were we were a Powerhouse
well you
not quite I mean there was there was a
it was more of the collapse of the
previous regime and then the rebooting
of it that I was very much in favor of
and supported uh but
uh and so I agree with that I don't I'm
I do think that some of the massive
social economic quality that has
resulted from that and also Mass
immigration has made Economic Policy
more complicated and difficult in terms
of the conservatives helping more I
thought it was her biggest base of
support were people selling their
Council houses for their own property I
mean that's how she and she was a middle
class low middle class appealing person
uh so uh
but
and we I mean it's still possible I
think it's still possible isn't brexit
really decision by the British that they
do have a future by themselves
I don't know man we live in a country
where more than half the population get
more in benefits than they pay in tax
how are you gonna how are you gonna
change that and also the the tax system
and the way that and and the cultural
attitudes are such that being
aspirational is punished or at least
disincentive I sort of hoped that had
changed uh yeah it's changed for the
worst since you were there I think
honestly there was a period in the 80s
and 90s where it was more of a um
a a defensive aggression and and and
Enterprise and
free markets right and now if you look
at the polls that that sort of at least
economic thatcherism it it represents
about six percent of the public well
partly because it it it it was a victim
of its own success in some respects
um and people acknowledge that things
change and it's not like a conservative
doesn't have a permanent ideology of
free markets it's it's free markets as a
function of a political society which
Thatcher did and but you should have
grown up I mean I was also growing up in
the 70s as it were
I mean the 70s
uh
as a kid you learn about your country
working around you see that every new
building is shittier than every peer by
a mile yeah no one gives a [__] the
country's shut down for four days of the
week with no electricity I mean the
whole place was just the shambles
um uh but again I think you know not to
defend Britain but um
to go from being the greatest Global
Empire to being a middle-sized economy
of in the G7
I think the Brits have actually been
psychologically quite good at handling
that compared to the way other countries
might deal with their decline
um in such a way and I think it shows uh
a tenaciousness and uh and also a sense
of the English nation and the British
Nation
existed long before Empire
it's
was no less uh something to be proud of
under Elizabeth the first than under
Victoria
um and that we have our own resources uh
and our own cultural resources I just
think that when you both lose power
internationally and then kind of tear up
your own cultural Traditions at the same
time you're going to create a very
unhappy listless meaningless
Civic experience and that's what we have
to be concerned about and the experience
with other people try and fill with
meaning
and patriotism is a tribal entity as an
expression of tribalism is a lot
healthier
than identity Politics as an expression
of tribalism because the one brings us
together the other tears us apart the
difficulty we have is it's very
difficult to be patriotic and I'm
patriotic about Britain I truly am it's
very difficult to be patriotic about a
country whose values you are not able or
allowed to Define
and that's where we are that's if you
walk up to a random person in the
British Street and ask them what are
British values they will not be able to
say provided they don't run away at the
question itself
and that's where we are now doesn't mean
I don't love Britain I do but perhaps it
was one of the most influential essays I
read growing up was The Lion and the
Unicorn by Orwell and and and which was
also repackaged as uh was it my country
whatever uh
because it was a socialist celebration
of the particulars of englishness and
English culture and English life that
was conveyed with such warmth and love
even in its Stern criticisms that it it
sort of it was the first thing I read as
a kid that talked about englishness or
what the English Nation could be or what
its values ultimately were and if you
would and so it came down to heavy
currency
ugly advertising uh love of gardens uh
all sorts of things he noted that were
that you even sense of humor
see I would say if you ask me that I
would say
common sense
decency
civility uh pragmatism
uh
prickly defensive one's own autonomy and
freedom still greater I think in England
than many other places uh oh for sure
um
you know it takes a lot to kill a
culture
we definitely we're definitely putting
that to the test but
um
I always have faith in your average we
can also get lost because we're in
educated circles and we you don't see
the very natural patriotism exists at a
lower level and this is true of the
intellectuals forever as well was
constantly telling us
um I I don't see my life as one in which
I rejected Britain for America
because I love both places
um I just think I personally was
temperamentally much more likely to be
happy here
um and I think that has proven to be the
case although you never you never know
um I wanted to be doing things because I
of what they were as opposed to proving
to that person I wasn't this person this
avoiding that trap all those social
signals that are that are sending into
your brain telling you to do things and
I was like [__] that [__] what I want to
do how do I want to express myself and
I've done that and the country has has
been incredibly generous to me in Pro I
mean I say that given they try to keep
me out for 19 years because I was HP
positive that's the other part of this
it's also
crazy ass thing
um it has these bizarre obsessions
sometimes
um I mean see you're you know it's a
country that gave us this incredible
burst of freedom but also the Hollywood
Blacklist the Salem Witch Trials uh the
lavender uh Menace of the 50s
um it has these convulsions it's it it
this wonderful country of Freedom
Constantine actually put in its
Constitution you could not drink alcohol
is that there's a country ever done
anything that insane before since in its
Constitution it wasn't it wasn't even
allow localities to have I mean when you
think about RJ beats about trans
Healthcare you realize it's absolutely
completely trivial compared to what was
going on before the demand of American
the American Protestant establishment to
purify the people is constant and in
some ways wokeness should be better
understood as the final manifestation of
this liberal Protestant uh ethic of
moral Improvement for people uh in other
words Harvard is now gone back to its
roots it's the Divinity School teaching
the elite how to better represent the
religion that they down to the words
they use
the way they date all of it is it's
basically a Reincarnation of the old
American puritanism
um and that gives workness a lot of its
Force
it's it's it's cultural Force
I mean we call it the great awokening
it's because there have been great
Awakenings
um and if you think America is always
going to have these semi-religious
revivals but in the 21st century it's
had a collapse of actual formal and
organized religion it's not so
surprising it might take a form like
this the disgust etched into your face
of the idea that people should not be
allowed to drink alcohol proofs to me
you're still a Brit oh absolutely even
though I don't I'm a complete stoner I
don't drink at all I barely drink at all
um but yeah
um a country that allows people to get
drunk he's okay by me I mean it this is
what I loved about Boris in so many ways
is that element of englishness uh
I mean it is the you know the
consequences are you know
basically a country of functional
alcoholics uh it is by the way when you
go over there that's the first thing I
mean within a day I can't possibly keep
up yeah how on Earth do you drink lunch
time afternoon
it's like what the hell I can't do it
that's how you know you've become an
American
yeah yeah some of the most he's both as
he told us he loves both countries
Andrew we will wrap up with his uh what
a varied and Brilliant conversation with
you it's uh great to have you back on
the show uh as always uh we're gonna do
some questions from our local supporters
that only they will get to see their
answers to but before we do our final
question is always the same which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about as a society that you think we
really should be
circumcision
uh
in America about half infant boys a
little more than that or automatically
have the dicks clips
uh we're having this ginormous debate
about whether children can consent to
irreversible changes
uh in which we are desperately and this
this occurs again it's not people
selecting in for religious reasons of
some sort it is it is a it is a way in
which hospitals lie to parents and tell
them they need to do this and secondly
make money in all the labor and delivery
services that they can add to and it's
gross it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a
bot an active invasion of bodily
integrity and the weird thing is in this
country that when you raise that point
everybody said well done I'm just
bringing it up it's a little provocative
here but oh I agree with you people
people were appalled that I would say
that they get really really defensive
um
if I call someone's dick mutilated but
it is emulated at some level
um no one wants to hear about their own
people and they certainly don't want to
admit that they did something bad to
their kid or that they themselves have
something wrong with them so there's
this pushback it's slowly declining
um that's a rather trivial uh answer
that question but it's we've talked
about so much
um that maybe a little trivial thing
like that
um is worth noting
yeah I was going to say would you want
to ask another question no I'm done with
Andrew let's let uh no what I was going
to say is Andrea's been a pleasure
having you back I recommend everyone
read the weekly dish please uh subscribe
to the weekly subscribe to the where you
have to now to read it it's all
paywalled as far as I can tell no it's
not it's not it's not enough you can get
the column every week and a bunch of
other little things for free and you can
get an hour of the podcast for free
um just the last half hour you have to
pay a little bit for and full a range of
things that the dish offers you have to
pay something fantastic well I really
recommend everybody do that follow you
on Twitter Etc Andrew we're gonna take
you over to locals uh that camera I
think join us on locals head on over
there we're going to ask you bonus
questions to Andrew
do you believe that U.S government
agencies have gone too far in their
quest to eliminate so-called
disinformation misinformation and Mal
information I'd love to know your
thoughts about Matt tabi's Twitter files
reporting
[Music]